gee when it comes to our tags we don't
often script them out or necessarily
know when the films start shooting what
the tags are going to be I don't drink -
what do you drink tea and late into the
shooting of strange the thor ragnarok
script was coming together and as we
were reading we said the scene could be
hilarious
wouldn't it be funny to answer the
question right away what's it going to
be like when Doctor Strange enters the
Marvel Universe and so I keep a watch
list of individuals and beings from
other realms that may be a threat to
this world your adopted brother Loki is
one of those beings were the inclusion
yeah I'm not sure if they had met before
but they got along great and I think
people are starting to learn this about
Chris and they'll soon hopefully know
about it Benedict Cumberbatch
they are both hilarious they are both
have the best comedic timing especially
for guys known as dramatic actors and
his action stars some of the finest
people ever meet and I think they really
enjoy the opportunity to just improv it
and play with what its kind of a little
bit of a lighter toned and the movie
that preceded it I can't pay rent with
the things one's a pumpkin how many saws
Guardian coins they're not worth and in
a god those coins these coins are worth
gazillion human dollars okay that is a
gazillion you're rich then do it because
no one will exchange the go to the
market set up a store yeah and right
yeah Asgardian where previously owned by
four I'm a celebrity that will sell like
hotcakes you might even think about
getting a getting a job job you serious
yeah I have a job you know my job is I
saved the planet yet maybe you should
get a job I have a job really dealing
the machine with the words that come out
of it this is knowledge knowledge is out
no it's not knowledge is not power that
the brain is a muscle and that's a
muscle and that's a muscle now you're
all muscle this is all muscle so I am
covered in brains and had more brains
than you so do you think maybe we could
just think that we need to serve it I
don't think we can get a certain get a
serve we got a baby we're getting better
getting a servant
hey youtubers its charlie oh my god so
much dr. strange so much still ragnarok
coming let's break it down the whole
thing here is that dr. strange is now
out on digital I think the DVD isn't
coming out for a little bit longer but
you can still get all the bonus features
if you buy Amazon so they've been
dropping a whole bunch of stuff
obviously thor ragnarok is coming later
this year they'll start dropping that
pretty soon as we get through guardians
right now guardians is a priority but
I'll say new round of the giveaway and
because the DVD stuff is happening right
now it'll be for a copy of the DVD or
digital or whatever you guys want all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts there's going to be a whole bunch
of Marvel stuff rolling out this spring
there was just this dead period at the
beginning of the year when almost
nothing was happening and then boom
infinity war drops and everyone starts
freaking out so let's talk about Doctor
Strange Thor Ragnarok crossover because
not only is he in this post-credit scene
he is going to appear himself in Thor
Ragnarok will say Doctor Strange is
pulling a Tony Stark wherein he's not
going to get another movie of his own
for a while even though the director
scott derrickson said he already knows
what he wants to do more Dormammu clea a
lot of the other things from the Doctor
Strange comics that they didn't have
time for in the first movie but because
Marvel's schedule is so packed between
phase 3 phase 4 they have all the
Captain Marvel black panther new
characters business going on that it's
probably going to be phase 4 before we
see another Doctor Strange movie and the
same goes for Ironman there might not
ever be another Ironman solo film again
just because Robert Downey jr. is
getting older and older but the age of
the crossover is upon us
even over at Fox with the Deadpool
movies they talked about doing smaller
movies that are crossovers character
pairing that you normally wouldn't see
that is why the Hulk made it into Thor
Ragnarok because they're like well we're
not going to be able to do a hulk solo
movie because of legal mumbo-jumbo
behind the scenes they don't have the
rights to distribute it even though they
have the rights to the character is a
whole mess so what do they do they want
to give him a movie so they put him in
thor ragnarok and they allow him to be
full-on hulk wearing his armor from
Planet Hulk when he's on earth he is a
day
to everyone people would die if he lost
his but in space on Asgard he can
be his full self without having to worry
about squishing people if he sits down
without looking first this post-credit
scene pretty much says exactly what
Doctor Strange is going to be doing
during Thor Ragnarok he'll find Odin on
earth so that Loki and Thor will get the
hell out it seems like he could go
either way on Thor but he definitely
doesn't want Loki on earth any time soon
just because of all that Avengers
business if you remember that ant-man
post-credit scene where Bucky's chained
up cap is talking to him you know me I'm
your friend that actually felt later in
Captain America Civil War that didn't
happen right at the beginning of the
movie so that might be what's happening
during Thor Ragnarok where Odin is
missing for a giant portion of the film
because we already have the synopsis for
Thor Ragnarok Thor is stuck on the other
side of the galaxy without his hammer
forced to fight the Hulk in an arena for
the sheer enjoyment of the Grand Master
Loki and anybody else that wants to
check it out because the loki appears
with Thor in the behind-the-scenes that
just means that at some point Loki helps
store escape or helps bring him to earth
so that they can find Odin and help fix
all the craziness that's going on in
Asgard with hellas character because she
is mistress of death even though the
movies always change minor themes from
the comics she basically has the ability
to Cole souls from as Guardians so that
might have something to do with the soul
gem but I know a lot of people want the
soul gem to show up in Black Panther no
worries we will find out one way or
another where that gem is when we get to
Thor Ragnarok because if it's not there
then it has to show up during Black
Panther in Thor doesn't talk about the
gems when he's talking to dr. Strange's
his post-credit scene but he has the
time gem so at some point maybe at the
beginning of infinity war or during Thor
Ragnarok when he's walking around with
Thor they'll talk about that because
Doctor Strange shows up right at the end
of the event of Santos quest the story
of how he goes around collecting all the
gems putting them in the Infinity
Gauntlet so at the beginning of Infinity
Gauntlet the book that we saw in that
Avengers infinity war teaser he just
studying things in all of a sudden in
comes crashing the Silver Surfer
heralding the doom of fan oohs and
plan to wipe out half of all life in the
universe so I'll have to do a longer
video about Thanos quests and all that
but the really cool thing is is that
Doctor Strange is a really important
part of being one of the first people to
learn about the threat amongst the
Avengers the people on earth then you
guys will be really happy about this
then spider-man shows up the Hulk shows
up they kind of touch base with all the
earth-based Avengers that are part of
this storyline so early on even
Spiderman was a part of that original
Infinity Gauntlet storyline so
spider-man Doctor Strange the Hulk
everybody meeting up in really funny
ways between Thor Ragnarok and infinity
war so just expect really big things
from Doctor Strange as we go through
phase 3 phase 4 he's going to be a
really important character even if he
doesn't get his own solo movie again for
a while
so we got new flash coming later tonight
I'll post a new Thor Ragnarok later this
week and there'll be a whole bunch of
other DC and Marvel stuff happening in
between congratulations to the winner of
the new spider-man giveaway Daniel Adams
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I just started that
Doctor Strange giveaway in this video so
I'll announce the winner the next time I
post a Marvel video while you wait to
that you can click here to rewatch that
full team thor clip and you can click
here to rewatch all the infinity war
craziness thank you so much for watching
everyone let's high-five I'll see you in
the next video